Namo tassa bhago vato hara hato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhago vato hara hato samma sambuddhassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Homage au Bouddha, le noble bienheureux, totalement éveillé de par lui-même.
Yesterday,
nous avons regardé la proposition selon laquelle personne ne peut nous causer de douleurs psychologiques et cela nous a conduit à la souffrance que nous nous causons à nous-mêmes et en méditation de toute façon nous les appelons
et dans la méditation en tous les cas on les appelle les obstacles et notre travail c'est de savoir quoi faire quand ces obstacles arrivent et comment les empêcher d'arriver et rappelez-vous que ce n'est pas un supprimer de ce qu'il y a
Et souvenez-vous, il ne s'agit pas de réprimer ce qu'il y a, mais de le garder au niveau du ressenti.
Il faut nous souvenir que dès que ces obstacles deviennent
Une pensée, elle.
Donc un courant de pensée.
Elle se développe.
C'est impossible pour moi de me souvenir de ma dernière phrase.
Ma mémoire est très moderne.
Je ne me souviens que de petits morceaux de sang.
Quelque chose comme ça.
Donc maintenant, je veux prendre ça un peu plus loin et regarder la proposition que nous créons nos propres mondes.
Donc maintenant j'aimerais aller un peu plus loin et donc rentrer plus en détail autour de l'idée selon laquelle nous créons notre propre souffrance.
Notre propre monde.
Et ça, cela nous conduit à une discussion autour du karma.
Et là-bas, peut-être qu'on va pouvoir comprendre un peu plus le non-soi, ou l'enseignement au sujet du non-soi.
D'abord, il faut que nous soyons clairs sur ce que nous signifions par le mot kamma,
Parce que le mot karma est maintenant dans notre langue, ce qui signifie que tout ce qui nous arrive, c'est notre faute.
Donc si vous passez par la rue et que vous tombez dans un manhole, c'est votre faute.
Donc si le long du chemin vous avez fait une faute, c'est ça ?
Vous tombez dans un trou.
C'est votre faute.
C'est votre karma.
La chose importante, d'abord, c'est d'entendre la façon dont le Bouddha a compris comment les choses se passaient au début.
Ce qui est important, c'est de comprendre la manière dont le Bouddha a compris comment les choses arrivaient en tout premier lieu, au départ.
Pas au départ de manière historique, mais comment ça se passe maintenant.
Il dit qu'il y a deux causes pour quelque chose qui arrive maintenant.
Il a dit qu'il y avait deux causes pour que quelque chose apparaisse maintenant.
Donc le premier, c'est quelque chose que nous comprenons très rapidement, cause et effet.
Donc quelque chose se passe dans le passé qui affecte le futur et nous expérimentons quelque chose qui a été causé dans le passé.
Donc quelque chose arrive dans le passé qui affecte le futur et nous expérimentons quelque chose qui est arrivé dans le passé.
Il y a quelque chose de positif et de négatif à ce fait.
Parce que je suis allé travailler, j'ai reçu un salaire et parce que je ne suis pas allé, je n'en ai pas reçu.
Bien sûr, cela prend une signification particulière dans la vie éthique.
Et l'Église catholique également reconnaît cela.
Donc, on peut pécher par action ou par omission.
Donc,
Donc de ne pas faire quelque chose que nous devrions faire aussi peut causer du mal.
Donc on a une ligne d'énergie qui vient dans le présent du passé.
Maintenant, dans le moment présent, il y a un rencontre de plusieurs lignes de karma.
Et dans le moment présent, il y a une rencontre de beaucoup de lignes de kamas.
Donc, oui, tous nous sommes venus, avant d'arriver ici, nous sommes tous venus d'une situation différente.
Mais en arrivant ici ensemble, nous avons pu créer ce cours, vous voyez.
Mais ayant arrivé ensemble ici, nous avons été capables de créer ce cours.
Si l'un d'entre vous n'était pas venu, alors cela aurait été un cours différent d'une certaine manière.
Si nous pensons que chaque chose qui arrive maintenant c'est à cause de quelque chose du passé, à cause d'une origine dans le passé, alors c'est difficile de comprendre comment est-ce qu'on peut être créatif.
Et on peut présumer qu'il y aura juste la répétition.
un peu comme un moteur un peu comme un moteur c'est comme ça d'un autre côté si les choses arrivaient simplement parce qu'elles arrivaient sans aucun lien avec le passé dans ce sens-là
Alors il y aurait le cas où il n'y aurait pas d'ordre.
Une chose arrivant sans raison, sans raison dans le passé.
On va en parler plus tard.
Mais c'est la fusion de ces deux que le Bouddha a vu comme les raisons pour lesquelles les choses se passent.
mais c'est la jonction entre les deux que le Bouddha a vu comme étant la raison pour laquelle les choses arrivent donc il y a un ordre dans l'univers mais également ce qui ne peut pas être connu parce que vous ne savez jamais quelles lignes de cause vont se rencontrer dans une certaine situation
Parce qu'on ne sait jamais quelles sont les lignes de cause qui vont se rencontrer dans une situation donnée.
Par exemple, prenons le cas très simple d'un accident de voiture.
Donc un piéton marche simplement sur la rue et tout à coup il est tué.
Donc maintenant, si vous disiez ça à un bouddhiste traditionnel, ils diront que c'était le karma de cette personne.
Mais cela présume que cette personne était en contrôle de toutes les conditions qui venaient pour faire arriver cet accident.
It presumes that they were somehow part of the cause of the driver being there.
Even going far as to say that they somehow caused the car to be built in the first place.
Et même, si on va plus loin, que d'une certaine manière, il est la cause du fait que la voiture a été construite.
Donc, il doit y avoir d'autres lois qui expliquent pourquoi les choses arrivent.
Et dans le bouddhisme, on parle des cinq lois.
Donc, la première est celle que nous...
La première loi, ce sont les lois physiques.
La physique et la chimie.
Parce que dans ces jours-là, ils ont vu l'énergie primaire dans l'univers comme la chaleur.
Parce qu'à cette époque, ils voyaient l'énergie primaire de l'univers comme de la chaleur.
Donc c'est appelé la loi de la chaleur, mais on peut traduire cela comme la loi de l'énergie.
Et puis il y a la loi de la biologie.
Donc c'est appelé la loi de la biologie.
qui est connu comme la loi de la semence écrane donc si on pense à ces deux lois la première inclut les choses comme le tremblement de terre
Donc, si vous êtes dans un endroit où il y a un tremblement de terre et que vous en êtes affecté, c'est difficile de voir comment vous pourriez en être à l'origine.
J'ai un rival.
Oui, vous l'êtes.
Pouvons-nous...
Pouvons-nous éliminer le...
Pouvons-nous éliminer le chat ?
Il y en a quelques-uns.
Il y en a quelques-uns ?
Je pense qu'ils veulent venir.
Ils veulent entendre le dharma.
Je suis sûr.
Alors, qu'est-ce que nous allons faire ?
Pratiquez le métaphore.
Ils sont petits, ils sont petits.
Ils ont comme 4 ans.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'ils font ici ?
Ils t'écoutent !
Ils t'aiment, François.
C'est la meilleure chose pour moi.
Pouvons-nous les emmener quelque part ?
Oui, oui.
Non, non, non.
Parce qu'ils sont des chats de monde, et si on les emmène pour deux jours, c'est chiant.
Oui, c'est ça.
Do I carry on?
Are they gone?
They must I think they felt my bad vibes Ok, so where are we?
So we have the physical laws and
qui sont telles qu'une earthquake où les gens souffrent mais évidemment ils n'ont pas été de toute façon une cause de cette earthquake si vous disiez que c'était plus calme d'être là à l'époque de l'earthquake
si vous disiez que c'était leur karma d'être là au moment où le tremblement de terre a eu lieu alors là vous dites une affirmation qui est impossible à prouver et le Bouddha en fait dit que vous ne pouvez pas trouver les causes pour les choses qui vous sont apparues c'est impossible, il y a trop de causes
Et le Bouddha a dit qu'on ne peut pas trouver la cause, l'origine des choses qui nous arrivent, il y en a trop.
Par exemple, tous les gens qui ont été noyés dans le tsunami.
C'est difficile d'imaginer, je pensais qu'ils ont tous été noyés parce que dans leur vie passée, ils avaient noyé des chats.
C'est la même chose avec la biologie.
Si quelqu'un est né avec une maladie congénitale, une maladie héréditaire, c'est la même chose avec la biologie.
Si quelqu'un est né avec une maladie congénitale, une maladie héréditaire,
Donc la compréhension traditionnelle c'est qu'ils le méritent à cause d'une action terrible qu'ils ont fait dans leur vie passée.
Mais on sait que le corps dans lequel nous atterrissons est le produit des générations passées.
Il y a ses propres lois, ses lois internes, ses lois génétiques.
La troisième loi, c'est la loi de l'esprit, la psychologie.
Et les écrivains l'étendent également à la loi de la société.
Comment créons-nous des sociétés ?
Parce que la société est juste une combinaison de pensées.
comment nous créons la société parce que la société c'est seulement une combinaison d'esprit et il y a aussi la loi du karma et la loi du karma est concernée avec l'éthique et la loi du karma est concernée avec les actions wholesome et non wholesome que nous faisons
et la loi du karma a à voir avec les actions bénéfiques et les actions non bénéfiques que nous faisons et l'effet direct de ces actions c'est de produire certaines habitudes à l'intérieur de nous et c'est ça que nous expérimentons parce que
à la root of our existence there is this mistake this mistake of who we are or what we are which then goes on to express itself as a sense of me
qui s'exprime en un sens du moi.
Et ce soi se trouve dans un monde dans lequel il essaie de se rendre heureux.
Donc, seulement quand nous agissons avec une sagesse claire, ne nous agissons pas à partir de cette erreur.
Et c'est seulement quand nous agissons avec une sagesse claire que nous n'agissons pas à partir de cette erreur.
Et c'est pour cela qu'un moment d'incompréhension ou d'incompréhension
renforcent ce erreur originale.
Un moment d'absence, de manque de conscience, ou un moment de l'indépendance, un moment d'indépendance, un moment d'indépendance renforce ce erreur.
Oui, renforce cette erreur.
Nous reviendrons à cela dans un instant.
La cinquième loi, ce sont les lois spirituelles.
Et elles sont la enseignement du Bouddha des quatre nobles vérités, et ainsi de suite.
et c'est l'enseignement du Bouddha sur les quatre nobles vérités et le reste donc on voit que dans la compréhension bouddhiste il y a des lois qui se manifestent à chaque moment pour nous à chaque moment nous expérimentons les lois physiques c'est ce qui garde ce bureau ici
c'est ce qui garde cette pièce ici nous expérimentons les lois biologiques juste maintenant dans notre corps nous expérimentons les lois psychologiques dans notre esprit et dans notre cœur et il y a aussi les lois karmiques à ce moment présent qui ont à voir avec votre intention vous voyez
qui ont à voir avec notre intention préférer les chats ou à l'orateur ou à l'enseignant et les lois spirituelles qui sont aussi actées tout le temps juste parce que quelqu'un dit qu'il est un athée ça ne veut pas dire que les lois spirituelles ne sont pas là dans cette personne
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un dit qu'il est anathique que les lois spirituelles n'agissent pas à l'intérieur de lui il y a de la souffrance, c'est déjà la première loi toutes ces choses sont en train de se passer à ce moment présent pour créer l'existence de cette personne
Toutes ces choses arrivent au moment présent pour créer l'existence de cette personne.
Maintenant, si on essaie de regarder cela de manière différente.
Dans l'Ouest, nous avions notre enlightenment, l'enlightenment du 18ème siècle.
En Occident, on a eu le siècle des Lumières.
Et ça a été la fin d'un processus qui avait commencé 300 ou 400 ans auparavant.
c'était que nous pouvions expérimenter le monde objectivement.
Nous pouvions expérimenter le monde objectivement.
Ce que cela a atteint, c'était notre science et notre technologie incroyable.
Et ça aboutit à notre science et à des réalisations technologiques impressionnantes.
Mais cela a donné particulièrement aux occidentaux l'impression que ce qu'ils expérimentaient, tout le monde expérimentait.
Donc quand on regarde un arbre, on pense généralement qu'on voit tous le même arbre.
Donc quand on regarde un arbre, on pense toujours qu'on voit le même arbre.
Et que d'une certaine manière, on peut avoir la même expérience de l'arbre.
Récemment, à travers la science de la neurobiologie,
récemment à travers les sciences de la neurobiologie ils ont commencé à comprendre qu'en réalité il n'y a pas de monde objectif pour l'être humain toutes les choses que nous expérimentons sont complètement subjectives ça c'était la vue du Bouddha et des anciens
Certains d'entre vous savent que le Bouddha ne répondait pas à toutes les questions qui lui étaient posées.
Et ils sont appelés les questions indéterminantes, les questions indéterminées, les questions non déterminées.
Elles sont appelées les indéterminées, les questions indéterminées qui ne sont pas déterminées.
Par exemple, la question, qu'est-ce qui est arrivé au Bouddha quand il est mort ?
Est-ce qu'il a existé ou pas ?
Est-ce qu'à la fois il existait et n'existait pas ou bien est-ce que ni il n'existait ni il n'existait pas ?
Alors le Bouddha était silencieux.
Et la raison était très simple.
C'est que celui qui posait la question avait toujours dans l'idée que quelqu'un était en train de mourir ou quelqu'un mourait.
Et cela va devenir encore plus évident pour nous avec les deux questions suivantes.
est-ce que le monde est éternel ou pas ?
est-ce qu'il est infini ou pas ?
maintenant, parce qu'il n'y avait pas de distinction entre le monde et la conscience cela a créé un dilemme pour le Bouddha si il disait que le monde était infini
infini et éternel, il aurait été accusé d'être un éterneliste.
En d'autres termes, la conscience vivait pour toujours.
Si il avait dit que c'était infini et non éternel, il aurait été accusé d'être un annihilationiste.
Il avait dit que le monde était fini et non éternel.
Il aurait été accusé d'être un nihiliste.
Il aurait été accusé de dire que l'âme mourait.
Donc l'âme signifiant le soi.
C'était la même chose à l'époque.
So he remained silent.
This is very much like the question you can ask an innocent person.
Have you stopped robbing banks?
If he says yes, it means he has been robbing banks and now he's stopped.
Si il dit non, ça veut dire qu'il va continuer à attaquer les banques.
Donc il faut faire attention à la question.
Ses réponses à ces questions étaient toujours
sa réponse à ces questions était toujours que les choses arrivent parce qu'elles dépendent d'autres choses et qu'il ne pouvait pas voir le début du karma donc quoi que ce soit qui arrive
Et c'est de là que nous retirons notre sens de la continuité.
On n'expérimente pas le corps qui disparaît et réapparaît.
Complètement différent.
Non.
C'est ce long processus, moment après moment, de quelque chose qui meurt et de quelque chose qui apparaît.
Et la connexion entre les deux garde certaines causes du passé.
C'est ça, ça garde des causes.
Donc ce n'est pas le même, ni différent.
donc ce n'est ni identique ni différent maintenant non non non donc où sommes-nous maintenant ?
oui donc ici nous avons une conscience qui à travers le corps et les sens est constamment construisant le monde
et en permanence en train de construire le monde et le monde qu'il construit est le seul monde qu'il peut connaître donc mon monde le monde dans lequel je vis n'est pas le même que votre monde nous sommes dans cette chambre maintenant
le bouddhisme ne dénierait pas la réalité de cette pièce le bouddhisme Theravada certains d'entre vous savent peut-être que le bouddhisme est devenu un idéalisme bien plus tard mais nous tous expérimentons et voyons la pièce différemment
Mais on expérimente et voit cette pièce tous différemment.
Donc, de manière subjective, il y a autant de pièces ici qu'il y a de gens.
Et on ne peut pas connaître la pièce de l'autre.
On peut donc...
essayez de la décrire, on peut la peindre, on peut écrire un poème, mais on ne peut pas l'expérimenter.
Donc, quand on comprend qu'on crée notre propre monde, on peut voir que personne ne peut nous causer de souffrance.
Mais il y a ce jeu, ce contact,
mais il y a cet endroit de contact où l'esprit contacte le monde à travers le corps quand le Bouddha parle du corps dans la méditation il ne se réfère pas tant que ça au corps physique
mais au corps qui sent le corps à travers les sens donc la rétine de l'œil est le point où l'esprit touche la matière et quelle que soit la capacité de cette base de sens elles sont les limites
Quelles que soient les capacités de ce sens ou de ces sens, ils sont la limite de notre expérience.
Par exemple, si nous sommes aveugles, on ne verra pas le monde.
Donc ici nous voyons que le monde que nous créons est dépendant du contact avec le monde.
mais ce que nous faisons à l'intérieur de nous vient d'un endroit différent notre réaction à lui donc juste pour revenir aux gens qui sont nés avec des maladies héréditaires
Donc pour retourner aux gens qui sont nés avec des maladies héréditaires.
Quand j'étais à Amarawati, il y avait un jeune homme qui était là-bas.
Et il souffrait d'une malfunction qui a fait que tout son corps était paralysé et tourné.
Il souffrait d'un handicap qui rendait tout son corps paralysé et déformé.
Et cela a commencé à arriver à l'âge de 10 ans.
Ses parents ont été dit par les docteurs qu'il serait presque impossible pour leur prochain enfant d'avoir cette maladie.
et ses parents ont dit aux docteurs qu'il y avait une très petite chance que l'enfant d'après ait la même maladie.
Donc, ils ont eu une petite fille qui a finalement développé cette maladie.
Maintenant,
Je connaissais ce jeune homme et il était extrêmement à l'aise avec cette situation.
Et il l'avait vu comme une voie spirituelle.
Et quand vous l'avez rencontré,
Donc, quand on le rencontrait, on avait l'impression qu'il était globalement heureux, comme la plupart d'entre nous.
Bien que je n'ai jamais rencontré la sœur, j'ai entendu dire qu'elle en souffrait beaucoup.
Elle était très amère.
C'est ce que je me suis dit.
ici nous avons une réaction complètement différente à une situation donnée et le monde dans lequel cette jeune femme vit est créé par elle
Donc quand on contemple le fait que le monde dans lequel je vis, c'est le monde que je crée, cela nous conduit à investiguer comment est-ce qu'on le fait, comment est-ce qu'on le crée.
Et où est-ce qu'on a faux ?
Donc comment ça se fait que souvent on finit en étant souffrant ?
Donc ici cela nous donne un certain espoir.
Parce que maintenant on connaît les confins de notre investigation.
On n'a pas besoin d'aller à l'extérieur de nous-mêmes.
Non.
La réponse réside juste à l'intérieur.
Juste ici.
Ça ne vous rend pas heureux ?
Je n'ai rien à faire au sujet de quelqu'un d'autre.
Même pas de vous.
donc quand nous investiguons et que nous regardons à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes comment nous créons le monde ?
comment nous créons le monde ?
Ça nous amène dans le noyau de notre problème.
Donc quand nous nous investiguons nous-mêmes, cela devrait nous conduire à la cause, à l'origine même de nos problèmes.
Quand nous méditons, nous trouvons cette position en nous-mêmes de pouvoir objectifier le monde intérieur.
Le monde intérieur.
Tout ce que vous voyez est quelque chose que vous regardez.
chaque chose que vous voyez c'est quelque chose que vous regardez et nous sommes laissés avec ce sentiment d'être l'observateur celui qui ressent celui qui expérimente donc même à ce niveau il y a un sens de soi
même à ce niveau il y a un certain sens du soi si nous continuons à guider l'attention en direction de l'objet que ce soit quelque chose d'agréable désagréable ou simplement la respiration nous pouvons expérimenter même pour un moment une absorption dans l'objet
Il se peut que nous expérimentions même pour un simple moment une absorption dans l'objet.
Souvent, quand on sort de ça, on reconnaît cela juste pour ce moment.
Il n'y avait ni soi, ni temps.
Et pourtant, il y avait une expérience directe.
et nous sommes allés dans cette expérience sans avidité et sans haine seulement avec le désir de comprendre donc quand cela nous arrive vous voyez, réfléchissez sur
les qualités de cette expérience quand cela nous arrive, réfléchissons sur la qualité de l'expérience maintenant, quand on retourne à l'observateur selon la psychologie bouddhiste il peut y avoir seulement une conscience à une fois
d'après la psychologie bouddhiste il ne peut y avoir qu'une conscience à un moment donné donc ce qui arrive c'est qu'à un moment il y a la perception de la douleur et le moment d'après il y a la perception du soi dans le état de l'observeur
dans l'état de l'observateur où vous vous ressentez vous-même comme étant l'observateur ce sentiment d'être l'observateur est aussi un objet donc vous ne pouvez pas être ça c'est juste autant un objet que le sentiment
c'est juste autant un objet que le ressenti que vous expérimentez la conscience de soi est quelque chose qui d'une certaine manière attrape un sentiment de soi ou attrape
un concept fin de soi une perception de soi donc chaque chose qui vient dans l'esprit est organisée sur une assiette ou plutôt sur un écran ce qu'on appelle perception
Et cet écran, on appelle ça la perception.
Et la capacité de l'esprit de tenir un objet suffisamment longtemps pour que nous puissions le percevoir.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent le Pali, c'est Sanya.
Cette qualité de savoir est
donc cette qualité de connaissance et voir l'objet de sensation donc le ressentir et l'expérimenter et cela attrape le propre sens de lui-même à l'intérieur même du processus de perception c'est comme un écran de télé
Parfois, quand vous regardez la télévision, vous pouvez voir une image de vous-même à l'écran, en regardant la télévision.
Donc, quelle image allez-vous regarder ?
Donc, quand vous obtenez ce très fort sens d'un observateur, d'un ressenteur,
Donc quand vous avez un sens très fort d'un observateur, d'un quelqu'un qui ressent.
Et que tout le reste est calme, tranquille, immobile.
Donc tournez toute votre attention vers ce sens de la présence.
C'est le premier objet que nous fabriquons.
C'est le premier objet que nous pensons être.
Et c'est là que le soi commence ses constructions.
Et puis le monde.
je peux seulement espérer que mes mots n'ont pas ajouté à votre confusion mais ont clarifié le chemin et que de cette manière vous arriverez très vite à votre destination que vous soyez libérés de toute souffrance plus tôt, plus tôt que plus tard
Merci.